[Music]
let's go to ann in colorado springs
what's up anne
hi john how are you remarkable how are
you
i'm doing well outstanding what's up
my brother is a registered sex offender
do i let him see my children at family
events
what do you think
no
ta-da
so
i have a very large very close-knit
family i am one of six children
all of my siblings are married we all
have children and we
get together and see my family my
parents
at least once a month um and what did
your brother do
he
to join this illustrious list
okay so he was arrested when i was still
in seventh grade so a long time ago okay
for statutory rape on a minor okay
uh he was charged and he spent
a couple years in prison
and then he fled
and then he got re-arrested and
extradited back to colorado
and spent a couple more years in prison
so we haven't seen him in a very long
time
but my parents have seen him a couple of
my siblings have seen him
and my parents are really pressing
because he just got to a point in his
recovery where he is allowed to see
children
if the parents of the child approves it
so my parents are really pressing so
that he can come to family events what
are your brothers and sisters views on
this
it's about half and half
a couple of us
can't do it because of our professional
jobs won't allow it
a couple of us just don't want to
because of personal reasons
what do you mean your professional your
professional jobs won't allow it
one of my brothers is a parole officer
or not a parole officer a prison guard
so he can't be in the presence of a sex
offender
i did not know that look at you teaching
me things and
um yeah so
this
when i when i first hear the word
statutory rape i think of an 18 year old
dating a 16 year old this is not that
he was
21 or 22 when she was 12. there you go
that's a child
that is a child so statutory rape sounds
different than that that to me is
sexual abuse of a child
yep
um
and the fact that he's been in jail for
this long and is still on a recovery
plan tells me that things aren't haven't
gone well
yeah he uh he had a lot of trouble at
the beginning of it i wasn't fully
around because i was also 12 when this
all happened so i wasn't really involved
until i was an adult i didn't know what
happened i just knew my brother just
appeared for a while yeah was it one of
your friends
no but she went to school with me i
didn't actually know her but she went to
school with me and was in the same grade
okay
so here's the honest truth
you have a you know
and so your question is less about
well now i sound like an idiot um being
some guy telling you what you feel and
think so i don't want to be that guy
here's what it sounds like to me tell me
if i'm right or wrong
it sounds like your question is not
about whether your
brother
who has a proclivity for sex with
children should be around your children
or your brothers and sisters your nieces
and nephews
it sounds like you're struggling with
trying to participate in fulfilling your
parents fantasy that everything is going
to be back the way they had always
dreamed it would be
yes
that seems like what's on your mind not
whether your brother should be around
your kids
yeah and breaking it to my parents that
it's not the right thing to do for all
of us right
so
if there's consensus among the brothers
and sisters
then you can appoint a spokesperson you
can all have this meeting together you
can write a joint letter etc
that's the best way to do it
if you have brothers and sisters that
are that don't believe like i think
brother's all better it's gonna be great
i'd love for my kids to see their uncle
and then there's two or three or four of
you who are like you're crazy
um you you all can circle up that way
i would recommend if there's a break in
rank meaning there's some brothers and
sisters who are in some who are out
i would speak for me and my family
okay
and
this is gonna require hard conversations
but i want you to remember this
your responsibility
is to keep your kids safe
your responsibility is not to make your
brother feel better
or
your responsibility is not to make mom
and dad feel better
and your responsibility is to not to
make this fantasy of the full family
come true
your one job on planet earth is to keep
your kids safe
okay and if two years five years ten
years from now
you decide i'll i will sister
i will re-engage my brother on my terms
and then after 5 10 15 years
i determine
or one year it's up to you he's safe
then maybe
but given what you just told me
not around my kids no i have an 11 year
old i have a five-year-old no chance
zero chance yeah
and i actually would put it back on mom
and dad
if you are choosing
to allow your son to come into these
things you are also choosing to not have
your grandkids around
because they will not be
and so really this choice here is not
yours it's your parents
and they need to
bear the full weight of this and not
pawn this choice off onto their daughter
okay that makes sense
yeah
and i know that i want you to shift like
thank you for handing me this brick i'm
handing it right back to you this is not
mine to carry this is y'all's choice
here's my boundary and hopefully your
brothers and sisters will join you in
that
and then your parents will have a hard
conversation i have a hard choice to
make
yeah and i don't i i can't even imagine
what they're going through it's probably
a nightmare
yeah
a nightmare for many many years yes and
the nightmare is going to continue
because there's no more
now there's not a jail holding it back
it's going to have to be them or they're
gonna say come on back
lost prodigal son and then they're gonna
lose four of their other children and
all their grandkids
yeah
and so this thing is a mess it will stay
a mess
your job is to make sure your kids are
safe
okay
and to make sure when you do have the
conversation with your parents however
hard it would be treat them with dignity
and respect and honor i they are in a
hard spot but this is a simple simple
simple
call for me
if i'm your mom and dad i would talk to
my son and say we're so glad you're
continuing your program
can't wait till you get out
um we do have a family full of 50 or 60
little munchkins running around here
a bunch of grandkids everywhere
and
as the
senior mom senior dad of his family we
are not going to put you in a position
to compromise our family to put make
kids unsafe and have any sort of
question
about you
coming to come into play we're going to
keep everybody safe including you
brother just getting out of jail
and so we may have an adults-only dinner
sounds great
or we may
um do a special
um you know christmas morning or
christmas afternoon with just the three
of us
but we are not gonna put our grandkids
in that position we're gonna put our
other um sibling other children in that
position we're not gonna put you in that
position that's what i would do
but again who knows thank you so so much
for a call go with your gut you know ann
oh you know
your kids are lucky to have you